los ingresos de julián son heredé de
miles de pesos por mes donde te
representa el mes del año julián ganó 10
mil pesos el primer mes del año
que representan 10 más la integral
definida desde 1 a 5 de rd t
dt igual a 48 y nos dan 4 opciones pero
antes como siempre te invito a que pasó
es el vídeo e intentes llegar al
resultado correcto ok vamos a trabajarlo
juntos nos dicen que ella ganó 10 mil
pesos el primer mes así que este 10 es
importante y podemos ver que es el mismo
10 que tenemos justo aquí entonces esto
es bastante interesante tal vez
represente lo mismo puede ser y ahora
veamos por aquí tengo esta integral
definida desde 1 a 5 de rd tdt ojo esta
es el área bajo la gráfica de la función
rapidez r tm es la rapidez a la que
julia obtiene ingresos en un tiempo dado
en meses y si tomas el área
bajo esta gráfica de la rapidez esto nos
dará el cambio neto en los ingresos
desde el mes 1 hasta el mes 5 es decir
que tanto incrementar ese ingreso y si a
esto le sumamos el ingreso del primer
mes esto nos da el ingreso total desde
el primer momento es decir desde el
mesero hasta el final del quinto mes y
nos dicen que esto es igual a 48.000
pesos eso es importante entonces veamos
cuál de estas opciones es consistente
con lo que acabamos de decir julia ganó
48 mil pesos adicionales entre el primer
mes y el quinto mes esta primera opción
sería correcta si no tuviéramos este 10
al principio porque esta integral
definida nos daría el ingreso adicional
que gana julián del mes 1 al mes 5 pero
este 10 al principio me dice que a esa
integral le vamos a sumar 10 mil pesos y
esto nos da igual a 48 mil pesos
si el inciso dijera que julia ganó 38
mil pesos adicionales entre el primer
mes y el quinto mes
eso estaría correcto porque a eso
podemos sumarle estos 10 mil que ganó en
el primer mes y así obtendremos 48.000
pero lamentablemente no es lo que estás
diciendo
así que cancelar esta opción
julia gana un promedio de 48 mil pesos
al mes
una vez más esto no está bien observa
que es desde el principio es decir desde
el tiempo cero hasta el final del quinto
mes
julia gana 48 mil pesos y eso no es un
promedio y mucho menos de 48 mil pesos
al mes así que también voy a cancelar
esta otra opción
julia ganó 48 mil pesos en el quinto mes
una vez más esto no me dice cuánto
obtenemos en el quinto mes lo que dice
es que tengo diez mil pesos del primer
mes y después tengo el ingreso adicional
desde el segundo mes hasta el quinto por
lo tanto también
voy a cancelarla esta no es mi opción
correcta y espero que el inciso d sea mi
opción correcta porque ya solamente nos
queda el inciso de más vale que sea
nuestra respuesta para el final del
quinto mes
julia ha ganado 48 mil pesos si esta es
la opción correcta ella ganó 10.000 el
primer mes y si a esto le sumamos los
ingresos que yo obtuvo desde el inicio
del segundo mes hasta el final del
quinto mes obtienes un ingreso total de
48.000 pesos por lo tanto en efecto esta
es la opción correcta el inciso de y voy
a seleccionar la de lujo espero que te
haya gustado este problema porque qué te
parece si hacemos otro de estos y para
eso voy a quitar este problema y ahora
trabajemos con este de aquí la función s
tt nos da la cantidad de salsa de tomate
en kilogramos que produce una fábrica de
salsas en el tiempo temps en horas en un
cierto día
esta s tm representa la cantidad como
una función del tiempo no es la rapidez
cuidado que representan la integral de 0
a 4 de ese prima de tema dt de nuevo
pausa el vídeo e intenta resolverlo
bueno si ese dt representa la cantidad
de salsa de tomate como la función del
tiempo entonces s prima de t va a
representar a la rapidez a la cual
cambian la cantidad de salsa de tomate
con respecto al tiempo pero una vez más
cuando tomas el área bajo la función
rapidez esto nos da la cantidad de salsa
de tomate original y queremos el cambio
neto desde t igual a cero hasta t igual
a 4 así que veamos cuál de las opciones
dice lo mismo la tasa de cambio promedio
de la producción de salsa de tomate en
las primeras 4 horas
no esto de aquí no nos dice la tasa de
cambio promedio hay otras formas de
calcular la así que voy a cancelar esta
opción el tiempo que toma producir 4
kilogramos de salsa de tomate no este 4
de aquí representa el tiempo lo que nos
dice es cuánta salsa de tomate se
produce desde t igual a 0 hasta t igual
a 4 así que no en definitiva esta no es
una opción correcta el inciso se me dice
la rapidez de producción en t igual a 4
nombre eso sería s prima de 4 y no es lo
que tenemos así que voy a cancelar la
también y por último la cantidad de
salsa de tomate que se producen en las
primeras 4 horas si es justo lo que
habíamos dicho y es lo que buscábamos
por lo tanto esta es la opción correcta
y hemos terminado nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo